in the teams what were the biggest
reputation builders or killers
and for those who don't know in the
teams
and i guess it's the same anywhere but
it definitely is true in the teams
man your reputation is uh is everything
it's everything and people know who you
are they know
if you do something stupid and like
really stupid in the teams that's
everybody everybody knows a second
everyone knows it forever yeah
like uh if you have an accidental
discharge
with meaning meaning if you shoot your
gun when you weren't supposed to
and there may be some scenarios where
there's a little bit of leeway on that
but if you just do it in a dumb
situation everybody's gonna know about
it forever yeah and it's just like you
might as well just get a tattoo on your
forearm that says hey i had an ad
on this date yeah in your forehead if
you do something stupid
you know something that could get you in
trouble like just
dumb yeah you're probably gonna just
everyone's gonna know about it they're
always gonna think about it
if you get if you get fired from a
position
and you happen to not get kicked out of
the teams
everybody's gonna everybody knows i'll
just get out yup yeah
it's it's it's a tough community when it
comes to reputation it's a world oh
it's really cool it's it's wicked brutal
like
yeah you know every it's like a small
town yeah everybody knows everything
even though you're on other coasts
yep i mean i've done a lot of stupid
[ __ ] in my career and i was a
jerk off and dumb dumb stuff and been an
idiot and
everybody knows all that yeah you know
yeah you know most of the stuff that
you did fortunately is
kind of uh is like on the
okay side yeah i don't know i don't know
how to explain this but like
oh oh yeah tony got drunk and got a
fight at this thing yeah you're like oh
yeah yeah
it's almost made a big spectacle at the
big to-do with the uniforms and stuff
wouldn't it have like to do with like
the things that you kind of can't do or
you can't get away with or it'll affect
your reputation in a bad way
wouldn't it have more to do with how
good of a team you are
you know what you're right you just
called it right you know what it has to
do with
is it something that hit that helped or
is it something that is operational
or not yeah something that's operational
everybody knows
like if you i mean even like you'll hear
about a guy that gets lost
in buds in in you or like
gets lost going through the initial
training but when he got to the team he
gets on land
on land navigation and gets lost and has
to get rescued
bro that's just it's just gonna stick
with you forever
like like i remember you know i remember
getting like three briefs
about some guy that i was getting in a
platoon about where this guy got lost
how stupid it was
you know there was a highway he could
have walked the highway you could hear
the cars
everyone just made a spectacle out of
this kid and i mean the kid got out
because eventually you go man i just
can't have
this is horrible everybody just thinks i
can't and so yeah
so this question is actually is actually
a decent question because
that definitely does play a big thing so
for me and it's the basis
for a lot of nicknames on the team true
true you know
true yeah if you do something that's um
excessively stupid
or or just have bad luck like one of my
favorite
ones is bush you know bush acus yeah but
he he like was parachuting and when he
first got to the teams as a new guy and
in his parachute he landed in uh in uh
what kind of bush was that
some kind of a bush with thorns and what
yeah parachute got all tangled up and he
got was stuck
in there the guy's that's his name he's
great too he's an
awesome guy yeah for certain bush the
other funny thing is there's team guys
where you don't even know what their
real name was actually i was kind of
like that nobody knew what my actual
name was mine was just jocko
and that was just that was my civilian
nickname that my parents gave me
but the funniest was there was a guy and
i'll just tell the story
there was a guy and you know him because
i do but uh
but anyways his name was al
and i was always in his name yeah and i
was like you know i knew it was al
and then he was a heavy weapons
instructor so we called him big al and
then we called him big al 50 cal yeah
cal for like eight years right and one
day
i'm like uh you know we're talking and i
we're doing some we're going on a trip
or something i knew his name cuz i was
in a couple platoons yeah
i did paperwork yeah so i
i finally get to paperwork and this guy
was also a real quiet guy i mean real
professional real quiet
didn't say much and uh one day i'm doing
the paperwork and i go hey man i'm like
looking at the list of people that's
coming i go hey man i thought you were
going on this trip with us
and he's like he's like yeah yeah i'm
going and i go oh you're not on the
manifest here
and he goes no and he comes over he
points out his name and his name is
keith
yeah and i go i go i go bro i go
your name is keith i go you want it
that's a mistake you don't want me to
get a change and he goes no no
that's my name and i go i thought your
name was al
i go is al your middle name and he goes
he goes no
al's is not my name at all and i go i go
what do you mean why does every single
person call you al
and he goes well he goes well in my
first platoon
i was out doing something it was night
and i was
i guess i was looking around and moving
my head a lot like an
owl and so the guys started calling me
owl
and then over the next platoon that
changed from owl it just murphed into
owl wow and then his name was al and i
literally
would have told you this guy's name was
al and and he never corrected it he just
you know hey whatever you call me al
that's close enough
so i thought bf or somebody named him
so that's big al 50 cal uh
but you know what his reputation was
because there was a question about
reputation his reputation was awesome
because he was solid
he was a he was a former marine wasn't
he uh
i was he no that was 295. oh okay 295
was in the core
but but you know solid reputation so for
me and i i guess
i mean it's it's what you do
operationally is what builds your
reputation
and if you're a good shooter if you're
not you know
shoot shooting like an idiot um not but
you know if you can patrol well if you
have good field craft all those things
the real things right it's kind of cool
that's what's kind of cool that's one
thing that's in the teams
that's that's hard for them to erase is
what's your real reputation
as a real operator as an operator team
guy
that's the thing that all these people
that that
kind of come and go in the teams and
it's it's maybe it's not they're not
real
real team guys you can't fake that
you know and when guys get some guys get
shot blown up you know wounded and some
of them can't operate anymore it's not
like we throw them to the wolves
they want to stay in the teams we keep
them and take care of them and some
become
phenomenal instructors and yeah and just
go on and do great things
yeah i had uh they were going to keep
they if if ryan job would have want to
stay they were going to keep
a cuss yeah yeah absolutely oh you're
blind cool yeah great yeah
doesn't mean you can't listen to me when
i say go do this
[Laughter]
yeah awesome and and then contrary to
that
obviously the killers are when you uh
when you
screw up stuff operationally the other
thing is if you're an arrogant
egotistical guy
you'd be everyone's going to hate you
yeah and you're going to last long
because if you're
because there's some guys that are great
skill wise they're great operators but
they're
horrible to work with they're arrogant
they don't listen to anybody
they're not humble and those guys will
have a bad reputation too they got blind
is on
yeah they can't open the you know and
you gotta
if you want to evolve at all they'll
stay alive you know